hot off the foot of Nicola Sturgeon
doing similar in Scotland Downing Street
has just confirmed that it will offer
funding for those peoples who have free
school meals at the moment throughout
the summer that after an extraordinary
Rauh involving government ministers and
mark Stratford the England footballer
the Downing Street has just announced
that they will be providing the Treasury
will be providing a hundred and twenty
million pounds of additional funding
previously they denounced 63 million
pounds in crisis grants and that will
allow them to provide vouchers for
parents likely to be handed out at the
end of term worth basically good for
about six weeks worth of meals through
the summer period when many schools are
expected not to be functioning but many
parents still kept at home earlier this
morning cabinet ministers including
Therese Coffey appeared to be resisting
the growing campaign led by labour and
led by Rob health and the Conservative
chair of the Education Select Committee
to offer free school meals throughout
the summer but Boris Johnson told the
cabinet this morning that he would be
doing this move today Downing Street
welcomed the contribution of the England
footballer in the debate making clear
that he welcomed the intervention a
highly emotive set of tweets and an
article in The Times red box this
morning but insisting that that wasn't
the reason that this morning he made the
move that yesterday the government
appeared to be resisting